I just wanted to firstly thank you everybody that made your way out on a Friday
night in Atlanta's traffic.
Alhamdulillah.
uh wherever you came from may Allah accept from you your
tire rotations.
Inshallah
may Allah accept from the sheh his wind rotation that you know he flew in in
the plane. So inshallah may I accept that from um the format for tonight and just
a little bit of housekeeping.
So if anybody has to use the bathroom if you're new to the facility uh you
can grab your shoes and go out from the reception area.
There's a hallway and past the elevators is uh gents and ladies.
You'll get that there.
Uh if you need water, it's outside
uh during or after.
If there's no drinks here, but you know, if you need to have some drinks afterwards,
we'll have some socialization hour.
We'll have some coffee and everything that everybody can enjoy inshallah.
So, the format for tonight is a discussion based.
We get too many lectures, but I thought it's important to have a conversation sheh inshallah.
And uh it's it's hopefully a structured conversation.
We'll go into a flow and then um anytime when we're having a Q&A, if anybody
thinks they have a question related to the same strand of discussion that we're having, feel
free to interject. Hey, I want to just add or ask uh and if it's a
practical question and we'll take it up inshallah this way.
Good. All right.
So,
those of you that don't know me, I see some new faces.
My name is Imam Ahmed.
Um, you know, I moved here from Canada, Toronto to serve in one of the mosques,
local mosques. Alhamdulillah, we started this place uh almost two months ago um as a as
a as a hub for community learning where we focus on genuine conversations,
structured learning. And the idea is we want to aggregately raise the bar of the community
in terms of their knowledge.
And when we say the word community, everybody's included.
It could be young, older, professionals, everybody included inshallah.
um in Atlanta specifically ever since I have been here uh sheh I have come across
um
having served in different communities across I've come across a lot of cases of loneliness
that has led to not very good ends right uh an example that I had mentioned
to you recently you know a couple of days ago um and it's a lot more
here than other places and that loneliness represents itself in
various different ways in the community.
Uh I'm sure you're aware of the stats that you know one in five American
uh has actually thought about suicide.
And if we look at for example
within the Muslim community comparing us to the Christian and the Jewish community, we have double
the suicide rate than the Jewish and the Christians.
Wow. Right. we have double the suicide rate uh per 100 thousand.
Obviously, we're a smaller number, but if you do in 100,000, we have double that rate.
U and the question that comes to our mind is
that aren't we supposed to be the leaders
in
letting the world know how the community should be led?
And that's the first question.
But the second question is
what is going on?
Where are we going wrong as a community?
and especially you know your your experience of the 20 years of building a community being
part of a community for almost 20 years where are we going wrong where do you
think that I know it's a heavy question but let's start straight into the conversation
yeah
so the framing of the conversation is root rooted in a very particular
challenge
uh one that is oriented around self harm and suicide.
And understanding the reality of something like this requires us first to fundamentally
exert an emotional intelligence that doesn't assume an absence of intelligence.
When we say certain words, we don't want to think about it just in extremes that
you're either grateful or an ingrate and you just exist in these two buckets.
But you might be in this room as somebody who's been an active participant in your
local community, perhaps this community.
You might be a community leader.
You might be somebody born into a community or multi-generational.
And it still is okay to say that you might not know what other people go
through. Uh I was speaking at a masid that had about 500 people in the audience.
I was talking to them about the need for kind of needs assessment of a community.
How it is that we understand fundamentally what people are going through asking them what they
think rather than assuming.
And in the middle of the conversation there was an elderly woman who was sitting in
the front row on the sister's side of the gathering.
And while I was talking, she started to speak and she said, "We don't need to
do this. I've been here since this community started and I know what everybody needs and
everybody is fine."
And I said to her, "Sister, I can appreciate the longevity of your time here and
all the knowledge that you have."
Oh, sure. But last night I spoke to a young woman from your community who told
me that she has been cutting herself
because of the things she is struggling with.
So everybody is not okay
and using that as a precursor to the discussion for us to think out here.
You don't want to intellectualize conversations that are not meant to be intellectualized.
So you don't want to meet this conversation with a state of discomfort, not knowing what
to do, and then going to a default state that lacks emotional intelligence and says, "Well,
isn't suicide haram to begin with?"
Because communal responsibility necessitates us thinking as individuals who are giving up a Friday night to
be here in this space.
what responsibility do I have to that person
that they didn't have an access point or outlet for what they were holding and so
they had to turn to this thing instead.
A lot of people turn to haram not because they're bad people, but because there's an
absence of community supports and structures that enable them to have their individual needs met in
ways that fundamentally
all of us have to be comfortable with the reality that we could potentially be asked
about it by Allah.
Right?
He is asked by his son Abdullah when he sees his father in tears towards the
end of his life in an elderly age.
In a state of disarray, he believes that perhaps his father is leaving from the world
soon. And also
go from Mecca to Abbisinia to bring people back to Mecca just so they can continue
to make life difficult and harsh for them.
understanding the level of severity of his opposition to that early grouping of Muslims
and he says to his son I had three states of existence in this world.
There was the state I was in before I found Islam and I was an opponent
of the prophet of God.
He said a second state was when I embraced Islam
and had I left this world in that state perhaps I would have had a chance
and now in the latter stage of his life he's been appointed a governor
and he says in this stage he has responsibility towards people
and the tears he's shedding and the worry he has he articulates to his son all
of these people will have the ability to stand against me on the day of judgment,
saying whether I honored their rights or not.
I want you to think about it as a community.
If, God forbid, somebody in your community was trying to engage in self harm practices,
somebody in your family, God forbid, went through this type of pain, what would you do?
How do you know that that's what you should do?
And if you don't know what you're supposed to do, whose responsibility is it to figure
it out? Intention in and of itself is not enough of a variable to get through
these things. The measurement of impact that goes along with intention that requires an understanding of
how it is that you expose yourself to a knowledge base professionals
training that then enable us to meet the needs because the successful community is the one
that the most underserved and underprivileged needs are being met.
And if it's not Muslims who are playing that role, who else is going to play
that role? People don't turn to haram because they are bad people.
Quite often people turn to haram because there's not the social support mechanisms that need to
be there enabling people to be in a place where they're comfortable in voicing the struggles
that they have. People know certain things are haram.
They still got to figure out how do I live in relation to that.
Do you see what I mean?
Does that make sense?
And so ensuring that we have healthy community that understands the gaps that are being filled
are definitely not going to get fixed just by pretending it's not there.
But also having the humbleness to say just because I don't know what to do doesn't
mean that there aren't people who know how to do it.
And we create a community engagement strategy that says how do you deal with people who
have substance abuse issues.
The prophet Alisam has companions who struggled with alcohol.
How do you deal with people who really struggle with haram?
A young man comes to the prophet and says, "You have to make zalal for me."
It's in the hadith.
You imagine what would happen if somebody walked into most masids in Atlanta and said this.
The companions tell this young man to not approach the prophet in this way.
The prophet of God
says, "Come close." And he engages them.
Many of us know the hadith would you want your someone to do this with your
mother or your sister etc.
And he says you know no messenger of God right like may my life be sac
he's saying yasool Allah like I would take a bullet for you expressing his love for
the prophet of God and at the end of it the prophet puts his hand on
the young man's chest makes dua for ease in this struggle and he says after he
doesn't have a problem with it in the entirety of the hadith the prophet who's the
best of teachers doesn't say the word haram once
He meets the person where he's at, holds what it is that he's holding and helps
him to know you can get better through this.
Do you see what I mean?
It's all there in the hadith.
Subhan Allah. So I think the reason we started with a tough question is now all
of you are conscious about it.
So the question leads me to another this leads me to another thing that um you
know we have a lot of attempts of community right across America, across Atlanta and every
place begins with the right intention.
We're very conscious about building communities and five years later uh something happens and then it
gets completely derailed and that vision
that the and the spark that everybody started with it gets derailed.
So the question that I have is like you know we're living in a digital world
where we're so connected and in this world where our needs of connection are being met
through the digital world.
How do we bring the consciousness
of of building a conscious community in a hyperconnected age?
Well to start out you got to go to the basics right?
The Quran says Adam was taught the names of everything.
We understand the meanings of things through the names of things.
And there's certain words that don't have ambiguity.
If I say live stream, all of us know what we're talking about, right?
If I say camera, all of us know.
If I say chair, I say floor, I say ceiling.
I don't have to be unnecessarily verbose in an explanation of the term because everybody knows
and has a common definition.
If I said the word love to you, if I said the word compassion to you,
if I said the word goodness to you, if I said any of these words to
you, forgiveness, integrity, honesty,
you probably don't have a collective definition that's uniform, let alone even as individuals, a definite
definition.
How can you reach a destination that's ambiguous?
If you're okay with it, what I would want to invite you all to do for
a couple of reasons.
When I do a hol, I like to have people talk to each other.
The sheh was telling me that you all are a community that also builds around conversation
and discussion. And I would argue that likely all of you don't know each other.
And even the ones that do know each other, you've never talked to each other about
certain things before. The pedagogy cannot be front-facing only.
But you have to get at this juncture in your relationship with Allah to a place
that taps into your critical thinking skills as well as listening skills and not only speak
when you think you have the correct answer or avoid speaking because you're worried about saying
something wrong.
So turn to the person next to you, exchange some names, know each other's names.
What does the word community even mean?
Because how can you build something that you don't even know what it is or it
doesn't have definition to it?
it would be the equivalent of me sitting here and I said to you all go
there
and then that's all I said and then I got upset with you because you ended
up someplace other than where I wanted you to be but you would say all you
said was go there and then there's no direction after that you can't get to a
destination that does not have definition to it so let's turn to the person next to
us exchange some names pairs so everybody speaks and listens what does community even mean this
word. Let's talk about it and then come back and discuss.
But go ahead. We're bringing a box of markers.
And if you can see the beautiful white boards
for the guys and the girls, we're bringing a box of markers.
And once we have those definitions, we'll probably ask, you know, somebody to write them up.
Great handwriting. But let's talk about it just for a couple minutes.
What does community mean?
The word, what does that look like?
Let's discuss. Go ahead.
And everybody should be talking.
Don't feel uncomfortable.
seek refuge with Allah from shaitan and talk right we need to learn from each other
to grow something effective go ahead
what does community mean
to me yes no you got to answer it I asked the question okay yeah um
to me where everybody feels safe
to be able to share their problems with the person that's sitting right next to them
thank you that's great we need somebody with a good writing
hna
Is it okay that we're doing this?
Like Oh, perfect. Yeah, that's exactly what we do.
Yeah. Good. Yeah. Alhamdulillah.
Yeah. Do you know all these people?
Uh I know
some new ones, but most of them I know.
Yeah. Brother Honey. The front front row most everybody I know.
That row I know.
Second row is one person I know.
Few are new at the back row.
If people are new here, like they've never been before, how will they know that this
is where your space is?
Like when I came in for Juma, I followed someone in.
Yeah. Do you know what I mean?
So if they're new that like we've asked them to put up our signs just building
slow, but is there a volunteer directing people upstairs?
No. Like if someone's It says uh in the invitation unit 275 and our unit is
a 275. Oh, it says it.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay, good.
So people can just come in
uh if they enter we don't have the Muslim wellness center written somewhere but when they
enter like how these people walk in from that door it says 275
all three doors so they can visit and it says building 200 there's building 100 building
200 and 275. Yeah.
So amazing.
Yes.
Why is the AC not working?
Open that thermostat and set it to 65.
And there's another one on the other side.
Huh?
75. Set it to 65
there. Yeah, there. That one too.
Okay.
So, what are we coming up with?
What does this mean?
Community. So, it's not ambiguous.
Like, what what is that?
If we're trying to build it, what do we discuss?
Maybe we can hear from a few people.
Hassan, take the mic to people.
Your one hand is working.
Put it to work.
Show. Raise your hands.
You give it to Give it.
Okay.
support.
Somebody else
to be available anywhere.
You want to repeat that?
So that's so community means support.
The first sister said, I'm sorry I don't know everyone's names.
U feel free to share your sister Saddaf and to be available at any time anywhere.
Sister Aia Naza Nazia I'm sorry.
Yeah.
Somebody from the brothers.
Yes. Go.
Okay. Closer.
Sharing the pain.
Sharing pain. Great. Yeah.
Not that it's great to share pain.
That's a great definition.
Yeah.
Relationships. building relationships. Okay.
First things to know each other.
Beautiful.
To know each other.
Great.
So my understanding of community is a group of people that are sharing the same objective
and trying to achieve the same objective together.
So there will be can be many.
Great.
Okay. I think the one brother has a hand in the back and then we can
each other
knowing each other's strengths and weaknesses.
Amazing.
You can understand what something is by also knowing what it's not.
If we had more time, another way we would add to discussion is saying what does
community not look like?
M or we would answer a question, what does healthy community look like versus unhealthy community?
Because you can get together as people that share a common objective, but that objective might
not be good. There's a bunch of people getting together right now trying to figure out
how it is that they can bomb babies all over the world, right?
May Allah protect us from ever reaching this state of wretchedness.
There's people who are convening right now in racist structures and systems to think about how
they retain their power and privilege at whatever cost.
Just like there's people who are running mids right now trying to think out how does
it maintain only access to certain people at the expense of others.
Oh, you have to be in a place where you can recognize a common objective can
still be something that is devoid of what our tradition offers to us.
A community of believers in Allah, what should that community look like?
The shared characteristic is one that is built off of what?
Fundamentally,
conscious community has to qualitatively be conscious of something.
And if we're trying to affirm support, being there for people at any time or any
place, knowing one another, it has a root that can either be the cause or the
symptom of whatever the cause is that yields the manifestation of these things.
But a lot of us get together more realistically on sociological levels.
It's not a good or a bad.
It's just a thing.
We crave similarity and familiarity.
This is why you have a masid that is only one race or one culture, one
class. Somebody says, "Why are there masids that don't speak only in English?"
Well, my great greatgrandfather, if he was Muslim, he probably didn't speak English.
And he would need a space that spoke to his reality as much as I need
one that speaks to mine.
It's hard to build community when anybody can be Muslim that meets the needs of every
Muslim. You have to be comfortable with that.
It cannot have continuity of the same challenge that doesn't acknowledge the existence of diverse needs
and then has vision that articulates that to have space that everyone can access in a
place that's as diverse as Muslim experience in the United States is not an impossible endeavor,
but it still is difficult.
Why do I crave similarity and familiarity?
And what is then the consequence of it?
When there's not an inward rooted sense of identity, but it's outwardbased,
shared externals.
I don't have a problem with you being you.
I just don't know how to be myself unless everyone around me is exactly like me.
Wow. It creates a sense of agitation inward
because I don't know how to deal with you when you are different from me.
The prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam was deeply embedded in practice that enabled him to have depth
of perspective
and yield consciousness
that if we were to juxtapose the absence of consciousness to consciousness,
we could use words like presence, thoughtfulness, consideration, not running on default settings.
and he took the time to understand where people were coming from from diverse backgrounds.
Tell me, not in any critical way, not in any way that seeks to give continuity
to any form of arrogance.
May Allah protect us from it, but in a way that's just purely objective.
How will we answer to Allah that there are multiple masids built in the same neighborhoods
because people fundamentally just fought with each other and built new ones as a response,
but there's still not an effective shelter for women who are being abused?
How are you going to answer
the reality
that you have a house that you have that's as aesthetically beautiful as possible?
Because the idea of building a house of God as an objective for communal existence is
not to draw attention to the house but to draw attention to God.
Allah Allah. So when you enter into the house, everybody's supposed to feel the presence of
the divine.
How do the spaces you build
evoke that kind of consciousness
enabling people to then actually be from the mutin?
And if you want to build something effectively,
it's a lot easier to build club houses where you share externals.
It's not to discount it.
It's important that there's gatherings that people can come together where they do not have to
validate their existence to be understood.
You have to be comfortable with the reality that when a white cop shoots a black
person in the streets that circles of black people should be able to come together to
fundamentally affirm and find comfort in their black identity in ways that people who are not
black just cannot understand.
The same way converts have to get together, women have to get together, people who have
had miscarriages have to get together, survivors of abuse have to come together, people who have
gone through any lived reality have to come together.
But if you want to extend consciousness
the way the two of us are sitting up here, you got to in this space
as well as other spaces that you're a part of have somebody that's sitting on a
panel like this that gives you an insight on what is it like to be a
recovering substance abuser?
What is it like to be a victim of domestic violence?
What is it like to be somebody who does not have access to food?
You cannot have consciousness of this
unless you are actually going through it or you are willing to sit and learn and
listen from someone who has gone through it.
and you want to build a conscious community.
There's a deep wisdom that in our tradition
that whosoever is habitually believing in Allah in the last day
that you speak good, you utter good or you be silent.
And the default is you only speak when you got something good to say or you
don't say anything at all.
There's no fundamental way that anybody on this side of the room knows what it's like
to be a woman.
There's not. When have you ever asked a woman what it's like to be a woman?
Your daughters, your wives, your sisters.
There's no way that anybody on this side of the room knows what it's like to
be a man. When have you ever asked somebody, "What is it like to be a
father, a husband, a son?"
The idea of understanding how you create and evoke for your own god-given
abilities as a human
a recognition that yields that it's not a heavy lift.
You just got to deflate the nuffs, elevate the heart and then sit in a place
where you fundamentally try to comprehend.
And if you have to make it about yourself, understand what Al is saying.
All of these people have rights over us.
Your neighbor is 40 homes in every direction.
That's what our tradition teaches us.
So somebody is sleeping on the street within a distance from your house.
And the hadith tell us that you do not have iman.
If your stomach is full and your neighbors is hungry,
what are you gonna do?
You can only live in one room in your house at a time.
And if you think achievement is that that is what you have gained or metric of
success is how many people show up to your masid,
but they're still hurting, man.
They're in a place where they got nobody to talk to.
And when they try to talk to you, they then never open their mouth again because
you meet them with idiocy.
And I say it with love.
What would you do if somebody showed up here right now and said, "My sister cuts
herself."
She's expressing suicidal ideiation.
This is the frame that the sheh said.
What would a person of tawa or a community of the mutin do in response to
that?
And if that's not where you're at, how are you getting yourself ready for it?
There's four buckets of knowledge that are obligatory upon each of us individually.
Your
you got to know you can't pray my fudger as much as I can't pray yours.
Second, a foundational
bucket of theology. You don't just know how to pray.
You got to know who you're praying to.
Third, a bucket of how you take care of your heart, your inner self.
And then fourth, you got to know how Sharia applies to you in the phase of
life you're in. So if you're a doctor, what does Islam say about being a doctor?
If you are a butcher, what does Islam say about being a butcher?
You're a mother, you're a father, you're whatever you have actively chosen to pursue.
So if you're somebody who comes to pray in a masid, what does Islam say about
praying in the masid?
If you are building community, you are building an institution, you are building something that is
meant to remind people of Allah and be a oasis and a source of replenishment.
How do you do that in the local that you're in right now?
And to exert consciousness that comes from understanding.
You don't want to be somebody who experiences real hunger in order to understand what it
means to be hungry.
But you can still learn from somebody just by spending some time with them and understanding
their struggle before you intellectualize or pass judgment on it.
And the root of it when we do massa
on a communal level, it's rooted in divine judgment.
That's ultimate. I could do whatever I want to.
I just have to explain to Allah why I did it that way.
I'm not going to be held into account potentially for what I did and did not
do but had the ability to do and still did not get it done.
You cannot build a community that seeks to serve itself only
in a way that is just superficial.
If one person is getting abused in the city of Atlanta as a Muslim, who else
would stand up for them?
People don't have food to eat.
People are struggling with mental health conditions, wellness conditions, financial anxiety,
deportation struggles, all kinds of things.
How is it not something that is my responsibility?
And when tawa comes in to the picture, consciousness awakens,
I'm conscious of what?
The divine. And why?
Because I'm going to stand in front of him one day.
And what did I turn this dean into?
The last thing I'll say, and I'm sorry that I talk a lot, is that you
got to actually find joy in it.
You should want to be in a place where you help people in their time of
need.
To get excited about the idea that my dean teaches me that I should be the
one that's assisting people through their pain and through their struggle.
My dean is rooted in the legacy of a man sallallahu alaihi wasallam who met people
where they were did not find them to be people that he broke down but he
built up and helped them to recognize what was inherently good with them and didn't leave
them to go through their struggles on their own.
How are you going to know what somebody goes through if you don't talk to them
and ask them? When was the last time you went to a masid and the leadership
of the masid asked you, "What do you think we should be doing?"
rather than just imposing upon you.
How can any one person fundamentally know what thousands of people with diverse complexity to their
lived experience and identity just need?
This is what this woman did.
She said to me, "I know what everybody needs.
I'm not judging her, but how is that rooted in the sunnah, in the way that
you see and think and perceive
versus who is the one that thought they knew everything and better than anyone else?"
That's not our tradition.
That's the sunnah of a tradition that we want to stay away from and seek refuge
from. I yield to the fact that I don't know and then I go find out
what I don't know so then I'm doing based off of actual knowledge and not just
my whims and my conjecture.
Do you see what I mean?
Mhm. So leading to that, what practical advice would you give us whether it's the Muslim
wellness center or a few of the other administrations or the messages that actually are here?
They want to actually build conscious communities and also they want to be able to listen
and hear what the community says and have an open ear.
What practical advice did you think has worked in your experience or that you have seen
that here here are the three things you guys should start or you know that could
really put you on the path because it's it's it's it's pro it's a progressive journey.
We're going to fumble.
We're going to learn fumble.
But just making sure that our trajectory is in the right direction.
Well, if you answer questions for yourself, what does success look like?
Anybody could build something.
Do you know what I mean?
The idea is not to just build a building
because there's a lot of masids in this country that nobody prays in anymore because they
didn't build withan
objective fact. It's not judgmental.
And then they conjecture
without real data.
This is why young people don't come.
Here's the problem. But what are you basing it off of?
How do you know?
And when you go in with an assumption, everything that you process is rooted through the
prism of that assumption and proving the assumption
versus understanding what our tradition is rooted in and finding a sense of empowerment through it.
Not a sense of anxiety, humiliation.
Why does Imam Malik say I don't know to 36 questions out of 40?
Why?
And what does it then enable as a next step in relation to that process?
It's okay to say there's this hole I don't know how to fill it rather than
pretending like I do.
And when you say I don't know, then you can engage the people that are going
to be able to help you.
You want to have community engagement that has multiple entry points to it.
Look in this room right now.
There's like 50 of us in the room.
And how different are all of you racially, culturally, in terms of your age?
I don't know what anyone's socioeconomic reality is.
I don't know like a lot of you.
So I can't tell you what your lives have been like, but in every which way
you can assume people have diverse experience in the room.
So one of the best ways to be able to understand the needs of particular demographics
is to ask them.
In our community right now, we get about five people a week who take their shahada.
And we're not standing on a street corner passing out pamphlets.
I'm not knocking anybody who does.
They just make their way.
Our community, amongst the many things that it's known for, it's known as a place where
people come to take their shahada.
And I find joy in that.
Understanding and recognizing when we built out a program for converts in our community.
My wife is a convert.
She took her shahada maybe 27 years ago, well before I met her, has practiced Islam
longer than I have.
I've sat down with thousands of people who have taken their shahada at this point.
And despite having a deep intimate relationship with someone who's a convert and sitting with many
people who have gone through the conversion process, I still can't tell you what it's like
to convert. I was born into a Muslim family.
Who's going to tell me what it's like to convert to Islam?
Somebody who's done it.
So 15 years ago when we started a convert program at our center
I had a much smaller community base at that time.
Our community now we estimate is about 20,000 people.
Alhamdulillah. And it grows.
It started from a very small base.
In 1978
five students found it and it's grown now to impact.
And I'll come back to this a little bit later if I remember.
But when we did this more than a decade ago, I sat down with a hundred
converts in our community one- on-one and I just asked them to tell me their story.
What was it like to convert?
What was helpful to you?
What was difficult? How was it engaging Muslims after you converted?
What kind of resources do you wish you had?
What kind of advice would you give to people?
The questions then yielded more responses.
And because they have a relationship with me, there's a trust that's there.
May Allah make me one who honors that trust.
They're willing to speak and make themselves vulnerable.
Conversations lasted for two to three hours at a time.
And I was just sitting and listening and taking notes.
And then we took those narratives
and analyzed it for trends and themes.
And then from there we built out a program
hearing from the people.
At our center we have a women's initiative, a converts group, a Latino Muslim group, a
black Muslim initiative, a professionals group.
We laid the foundation for other entry points as well in addition to at New York
University which was our initial base of operation where there were 12 MSAs not in competition
with each other but just doing different things.
There's 4,000 Muslim students as well as students that came from all over the city from
other colleges that didn't have similar accommodations in addition to many people who live and work
in the area that just see our space as their community.
So, we were going to lay the foundation for an artist collective.
We had a families group that we were building out.
When COVID got in the middle, we derailed it.
But out of our center, we've also built a domestic violence agency and operate a shelter
in the Bronx for women and children who are survivors of abuse.
We have a charitable fund that supports 800 families in need in our community.
We have a weekend learning program for children.
We're incubating a full-time school right now.
I'm just trying to build as much as I can while Allah has given me breaths
to breathe in this world and building with people who want to build.
It's rooted in data.
And when I've shared with people different things or hosted conversations with people like panels of
converts with 10, 20 converts, giving them an opportunity to not just share the story of
their conversion, which is where most of us start and stop, but then I say, "What
is it like after you converted and after you became Muslim?"
and they talk about just how terrible it is dealing with Muslims in Muslim communities.
And then I have people who are humble enough in the audience to come up to
me and they said, "I've ran the convert care program, the da program in my masid
for 10, 15 years and I just realized I don't know a thing about what I'm
doing." Ya Allah. And that's the kind of person we need.
one who can say I'm not doing it the way it should be done not somebody
who pretends and then there's data to it not I think I feel I want how
many of you have ever woken up in the morning and thought about my grandfather
none of you it doesn't make you a bad person why would you think about people
that you don't think about who you have ever interacted with you didn't wake up in
the morning and say you know I wonder how Khal Latif's grandparents are
In the same vein, you're not going to think about the people who don't enter your
consciousness.
Doesn't mean you don't have responsibility towards them.
Doesn't mean that they still don't have rights over us.
and understanding the best person to tell you what their needs are are going to be
the person beyond the individual interaction that necessitates building a trust with somebody that they're willing
to make themselves vulnerable with confidentiality
and say this is what this is like for me.
You get to a place where you can do broader needs assessment and you instill within
your community development people who create spaces that are both individualized as well as communal that
allow for people to share so that you can understand a little bit about somebody who's
different from you. I got thousands of people's stories in my heart.
When people ask me how do the words flow, I got so many people who have
trusted me with what they carry.
It's going to inform perspective that is rooted in what is authentically our tradition, not rooted
just that my life is the only way life has been lived.
And this is why you got to think it's objective.
Just think about it.
If you have a masid, you have a nonprofit, you have a for-profit, you know why
a lot of us go through what we go through in this country?
Because pretty much every entity and institution is still run by people who check off every
box of privilege. The white Protestant male runs every single thing from city electeds to state
electives to national electeds to coaches in various professional sports leagues to heads of universities, CEOs
of companies. This is why you and I have to struggle to even let our kids
miss because the people at the decision table, they're making decisions about us without any frame
of consciousness. It's not enjoyable, is it?
So, what happens when everybody who runs your masid is the exact same version of the
other people that run the masid?
If every single person is a South Asian man like you, if every single person comes
from the same cultural, ethnic, lived experience as you, you ain't wake up thinking about my
grandfather.
When was the last time you woke up thinking about, hey, how do we meet the
needs of people who are dealing with these lived realities?
And if the only presence at the table is stereotypical,
well then you see the consequence in anti-black society of how that trickles down.
Don't make those people your teacher.
Your teacher sallallahu alaihi wasallam built differently.
He built a community before he built an ummah.
And that community was built on shared internals, cultivating iman in something that then allowed for
there to be a growth trajectory that started with handfuls and his last is given to
over 120,000 people
in a 23-year trajectory.
That's pretty remarkable. It didn't come because everybody that he talked to was only from the
Banu Hashim.
It just simply didn't.
And the s is an important thing to read because it makes the Quran concrete.
It just breaks down any justification we have to say this is why my masid turned
into a place where people who have as much wealth as I do and speak the
same language as I do or have all of these other characteristics in common with me
run it and decide how people who are from diverse backgrounds are allowed to have access
to it. That's not how you build effective community.
Just go and talk to people.
I've had grown men man who are in their 50s sitting in my office in tears.
I'll say, "Why are you crying?"
And they'll say, "Nobody's ever asked me what I think before."
Why?
Why would you want to pretend like you know everything?
Yeah. How is that a recipe or a key to Jenna?
How?
rather than the approach that says I don't know everything and I'm willing to hear and
listen and hold
and then allow for you to know that I acknowledge that your story is still a
part of this bigger thing and even if we can't do it now I didn't build
a shelter in year one of our work we built a shelter in the year 2019
I started working there in 2005 but I knew having met one to 12 women a
week who have know men in their life that have an understanding of what it means
to be a man.
That it wasn't just about sitting with them, but using a platform that Allah endowed me
with to say, "We got to build something institutional to try to help as many break
out of this beyond just a one-on-one discussion."
It takes time, but if you know what a community is working towards objectively, then you're
going to fulfill the objectives.
Mashallah. I started taking notes in the middle.
I'm like, this is too good for me to sit around and not take notes.
May Allah bless you.
Um, so I think um I'm going to uh
lighten up the mood a little bit inshallah and then we'll get back to some questions.
So these are some rapid fire questions that I have for you.
So we get to know you.
You've you've told a lot about you but you know we'll get to know.
So these are basically faith and identity related questions inshallah.
Was there a moment in your youth when you knew you were going to dedicate your
life to this cause?
Uh no I think I just kind of got
turned into it. Alhamdulillah.
Alhamdulillah. But I I couldn't tell you here's this one moment.
I could tell you that I met people who were just very nice people uh when
I was 17 and went to my undergrad.
The first Muslim I met was Indonesian.
I know this is not rapid fire.
Um I had never met an Indonesian Muslim in my life before.
And he was also one of the kindest human beings I ever met in my life.
His name is Rwan Falah.
Really beautiful person. I still keep in touch with him.
He was one of the first people who all I knew of him was just warmth
and compassion. We literally were walking down the street and a brother gave him salams, commented
on how he liked his scarf and he just took the scarf off his neck and
put it on him and says, "It's for you, but not with any sense that was
transactional."
And I said, "I've never met somebody like this before."
But he also was one who encouraged me to believe that I could have a relationship
with Allah. And Allah blessed me to meet people like that who despite what were perceived
inadequacies growing up going to a masid where everybody pointed out whatever reason I shouldn't be
there. He was the first person who helped me to understand that that's not what this
dean is rooted in.
And I don't know if I had not met him where I would be right now.
No, but it was just kindness and warmth that was this is what Islam should be
or bring you to.
What is one misconception people have about you that you're
that that they have about you because you are a public religious figure?
Oh, I don't know.
I don't even think about things like that.
Uh what is a misconception people have about me?
I think when I go to travel places, a lot of times people comment who have
only seen me on like a screen of some kind that they didn't think I was
as short as I actually am.
They said that I speak with a voice that seems like I'm a lot taller than
I am. And I said, "I'm sorry.
This is just how big Allah made me."
Yeah. Uh what's the hardest thing hardest part of being a Muslim leader in America right
now for you?
Uh, you know, alhamdulillah, I'm blessed to have a really good community, but I had a
teacher who when I first started working in this role, he said, uh, you're perfect for
this,
but get ready is going to be very lonely.
And I couldn't understand what he meant.
Uh, and for a long period of time, it was very lonely.
My self-care was non-existent.
I was getting sick all of the time.
I was building a lot of just inward angst.
And Allah has blessed me with the community that I serve that even as large as
it is, they check in on their leadership.
But I had to be willing to actually acknowledge that it was okay for me to
let people be there for me rather than having to tell myself I just have to
be there for everyone else all of the time.
And so I think that was something that was a little bit hard.
And I see it with a lot of Muslim leaders right now.
You don't fundamentally know what it's like when somebody reaches out to you with a death
threat. Like, you just don't know.
You don't know what it's like when somebody comments on every single thing.
I'm part of a community that does not do this.
Alhamdulillah. But I have kids the way you all have kids.
I'm married the way some of you are married.
I have a family.
I'm not the only one who my name is attached to, but there are others.
And I don't want my kids to feel like they have to live in my shadow
or anything to that extent and to understand the recognition of what we've been blessed with.
I see a lot of my peers and friends who they don't have the same thing.
People treat them like garbage.
You don't want to be people who treat your like community leaders in that way.
And you evoke support.
You exert compassion. You don't treat people in a way that dishonors the rights that they
have over you. And so that loneliness variable is important to be able to understand.
There's still stuff I go through today that people just might not relate experientially.
But I have to be willing to understand that love is a very important variable.
And I'll share this anecdote.
I had a student of mine who's in California.
His name is Afras Khan.
He graduated from our undergrad, did his MBA, does a lot of really good work.
uh he was doing a semester abroad and we were on a Zoom with some of
his other classmates
and I hadn't seen him in months
and when we got on the Zoom he got on and he
you know at first it was pretty comical because he hadn't cut his hair in a
long time and his beard was very he looked like he hadn't showered in a while
and I was like what's going on and then when he said salams to me he
just started crying so much Oh, and people didn't know what to do on the Zoom.
And when I turned off the Zoom, I was about 30 years old when this happened,
12 years ago.
And I turned it off and I reflected and I said, "Man,
this kid loves me so much."
And I had never really experienced what it means to love someone for the sake of
Allah. And acknowledging that that was a thing that I could name.
And when I was open to embracing the fact that he loves me, it created an
opening for me to say these other people actually love me too.
And then that opened a door in which I could say I love them also.
And there's so much in our tradition, right?
We can talk about it again.
Love, love, love. Why?
Because when you are bold enough to love someone,
it'll give you a courage unlike anything you imagine.
Ya.
And when you are willing to acknowledge the love that someone has for you, it will
give you a strength unlike anything also.
And what Shayan sometimes does is have us chase after the things that we already possess.
Adam is told not to eat from the
heats it, but what's he going to get from the tree of eternality?
He's already in Jenna.
it's not going to do anything for him in the way that he already possesses what
it offers.
And that loneliness is really, really heavy.
And I can tell you being on the other side of it, when people say to
me, "How do you get done what you get done?"
I tell my community all the time that I love them.
As much as I tell my children every day that I love them, I tell my
wife every day that I love her,
it is something that I can do and they experience with conviction because I also love
myself. And it's hard to fully love outwardly when you don't like yourself.
You cannot fundamentally like yourself if you need everyone around you to be just like you
in order to feel comfortable.
and getting to a place where you can acknowledge even if there's that one person who's
there with you, it can then ignite a fire that allows for you to say, "I
don't have to confine myself to this dunya."
Do you know? But that loneliness is what a lot of Muslim leaders are experiencing right
now. And you don't want to be a community that contributes to that when you are
building what you're building here or as she said that there's a lot of other I
don't know how any masid runs here.
Do you know what I mean?
But if you've been entrusted to be a caretaker of Allah's house remember it's Allah's house
and every guest has rights.
Yaam
is a big part of our tradition
and that means the person who you brought in to lead the community is still a
guest in Allah's house.
You treat them like a guest.
You don't treat them like a servant.
They are Allah's abd, not yours.
Do you know
they were supposed to be light rapid fires, but alhamdulillah the on to something.
So let's go to some easy questions.
Tea or coffee?
I don't really drink either tea or coffee.
It's not. I don't think this rap fire is going anywhere.
Yeah. Okay, cool. Uh, biryani or mandi?
Oh, I like both.
I'm not I'm not going to be good at this.
I I like I You have such diplomatic New Yorker answers.
I just I like everything.
I don't know what to tell you.
I told him, "What do you want?"
Anything. Like, I'm a 5-year-old.
Take me anywhere. I I'll eat anything.
It's true. Okay. If you had an extra hour in your day, what would you do?
Uh, I would hang out with my kids more, but we already do that a lot.
I don't know. I mean, I've I've brought a lot of structure to my routine.
Took me a while to put come up with these questions.
I'm sorry. Uh, I mean, I think I would do a little bit more of the
things I do now.
Um,
but
you know, I said this at Juma, I think, today.
I don't remember because I did a talk right after online.
I meet a lot of people who are going to pass away from the world when
they're in their last moments in the work that I do.
When you serve a community that's 20,000 people, every day somebody you know is dying.
And when I sit with people at the end of their life, I've never met somebody
who says to me, "I wish I had five more minutes to go to work.
I wish I had five more minutes to gossip or be racist or to be mean
to people at the masid.
Yeah. What they say is, I wish I had more time to just spend with my
loved ones,
to be a part of things that I wish I hadn't let go of.
You don't want to be afraid of failure.
That's a stupid thing to be afraid of.
This is not a religion that teaches us to pursue perfection.
What you do want to be afraid of is regret.
A regret that's unhealthy that says, "Why did I do it in the way that I
did it?" So, if you were to ask me what my work life balance looks like
right now, well, I spent a lot of time identifying and defining the way we talked
about community. What does life mean in a work life balance?
And I don't have to give it up in ways that sometimes people assume you do.
There's a lot more time in the day that we can structure things and allowing for
us. If I had another hour to my day, I think I would just create more
continuity to some of what it is that's going on.
But I had to learn the hard way.
When I was 29, I got shingles.
I don't know if anybody here has ever had shingles before.
You've had shingles. Was it enjoyable?
No. It's terrible. Right.
Yeah. And I'm not commenting on your age.
She forgive me for that.
You know,
yeah. Mashallah. Allah preserve you.
20 year olds don't get shingles.
You get shingles when you're at such a high level of stress and low point of
immunity. And if you ever had chickenpox, the virus reactivates in your nervous system as blisters
on a nerve track.
I woke up one morning and from the middle of my torso to my back in
my 20s, I had this thing.
I went to the doctor.
They said, "Get ready.
It's going to hurt a lot.
It's going to feel like somebody is stabbing you again and again while they rub a
hot iron on your body.
I'd spent most of my 20s in a place where I was coasting off of wellness
for my teens. In my senior year of high school, I got multiple concussions.
I was supposed to play sports in college.
To give you an idea, when I was 15 years old, I could bench press 315
pounds. I ran a 4540,
was very athletic, working out three times a day.
And when you go through that type of rigorous agenda, you can coast off of it
for a while. When I started working in this role when I was 22, a lot
of my sense of wellness and structure just diminished.
I wasn't spending time with people in any meaningful way.
I was always starting my day with anxiety in a rush.
My weight fluctuated. I get very heavy, very light.
And then this shingles thing happened.
After about seven years of not paying attention to the signs that my mind, my body,
my heart were showing to me.
I had to quarantine for a while because until the blisters pop and the liquid releases,
which is contagious, you got to be in quarantine.
So, I went to my parents house where I grew up and I stayed in the
bedroom that I grew up in.
And one night I was checking my email and I got an email from a student
of mine who said earlier that day her Muslim boyfriend grabbed her by the straps of
her book bag in the hallway of their classroom building and threw her against some lockers.
And she said had a security guard not intervened, she wouldn't know what to do.
And she was reaching out to me now for help.
and I closed the laptop and I went downstairs to where my mother was sitting watching
TV and I put my head in my mom's lap and I started to cry.
It wasn't that I didn't know how to help this girl, but I couldn't take care
of her because I wasn't taking care of me.
And my self-care did not make any sense.
My body had to implode on itself for me to wake up to the reality that
the hadith is true.
The prophet tells us, "Yourselves have a right over you."
Right? Fast but eat, pray, but sleep.
This is hadith. I wasn't doing any of it.
You command people to righteousness, but you forgot yourself.
You can't take care of other hearts if you're not taking care of your own.
And so recognizing the importance of having good work life balance and being in a place
where it's okay as a community servant to still take time for yourself.
When I got married,
my wife was a good sport.
She said, "You can."
I said, "I'd love to have a wedding ceremony where anybody could come if they wanted
to." And she said, "As long as we have a reception that is just our friends
and family, I'm fine with that."
We had
I don't know how many thousands of people showed up at our wedding, alhamdulillah.
But just well-wishers,
a lot of baraka in the room.
They came because they wanted to be there.
There's a huge masid in New York City on 96th Street and Third Avenue.
If any of you have been there, that day because of our wedding, they had six
separate jamas for user because of how many people were in the wedding.
A month into our wedding, my wife looked at me and she said, "You don't have
any friends." I said, "What do you mean?
Do you see how many people came to that wedding?"
She said, "You don't have any friends.
You don't invest time in relationships.
You don't have any deep friendships.
you don't have friends.
And every part of me denied it.
But she was so true in what she was saying.
Just as she was telling me, I wasn't taking care of myself physically.
I wasn't investing in things that were helping me emotionally.
She wasn't criticizing me.
She was helping me.
The nuffs is real.
It doesn't want you to be anything other than lazy.
So, I had to acknowledge it.
And then when I didn't get done what I could,
this is where I had the blessing of this illness
that woke me up to saying you got to take better care of yourself and use
the time that you have in ways that are important.
Another way that I would say to look at this, which is why, man, you don't
want to waste your time building in reaction to somebody else's foolishness.
Build with noble intentions, not with mal intent is a bad reason to build a masid
because you're fighting with someone at another masid.
How is that a good intention?
That's a ridiculous intention.
But in being able to understand and recognize how you contribute to what it is that
comes with the time you've been allocated.
I visit a lot of refugee camps, conflict zones, people in the aftermath of natural disaster.
I went to Rafa in December of 2023.
In Ramadan of 24 before I went back and visited children from Gaza who had severe
medical needs, earthquake in Turkey, Libya, floods, refugees, Rohinga, Syrian, you name it, I could tell
you about it. One of the consistent things from people I met on the ground in
all of these places,
when I asked them what you would like me to tell people when I go back
home and share and honor your stories,
all of them said, "Tell people not to waste time."
Man,
none of us woke up thinking that an earthquake was going to take the lives of
our loved ones today.
None of us thought that a missile was going to take the lives of so many
of our family members.
I didn't know that I wouldn't hold my daughter ever again.
And I wish the last thing I said to her wasn't the last thing that I
said to her.
Tell them not to waste time.
If you were given an extra hour,
don't do something with it that at the end of your life you are wishing you
had that extra hour,
but you are using every blessing of every moment as best as you can to really
think about not why things are happening in the world, but why did Allah and his
wisdom choose to create me at this time?
As your brother who loves you, he didn't create you so that you would hurt people.
He didn't create you so that you would just feed your ego.
He didn't create you so that you wouldn't admit mistakes, so that you wouldn't seek forgiveness,
so you wouldn't express gratitude.
But he created us to do the opposite of those things, right?
This thing of time, if you can get it in check and under control, that's not
overt and just thinking in extremes, but spend time with people that you love.
This is ibada. Also, I'm going to hang out with friends of mine who live in
Atlanta tomorrow while I'm here because it helps replenish my heart.
You make the people in your life also have the ability to use time in ways
that are replenishing.
And then it enables you to take care of other people.
I couldn't do right by this girl because I wasn't doing right by me.
Does that make sense?
Okay. Um so it's 8:31 uh salah is around 8:45 inah 8:45 I'll open up the
floor for if anybody has questions pertaining to the the frame of you know community and
how to build a conscious community if any of the masids have any of those questions
uh feel free to ask you Hassan do you want to pass the mic or you
you can speak up we can hear you
70 plus years.
How many? 70 plus years.
Okay.
And I uh never had
min
I don't know.
He went to get the shake.
I thought they were playing games.
I don't know.
Then I got to
see
Allah
powerless
in a way that I never Alhamdulillah.
Here we are. Alhamdulillah.
Alhamdulillah.
So, Uncle, as you can tell, Uncle Amir is the soul of our place, right?
Alhamdulillah. May Allah preserve him for us.
Mashallah. Yeah. May Allah keep you safe all the time.
Inshallah. If he misses a Juma, we're like, where did he go, right?
Because we're looking forward to that.
So, may Allah bless you.
But do you see how you benefit from his vulnerability
to be in a place where so much of the world you live in causes you
to hide and not share and express.
But when you ask somebody how they are, this is not a religion that says that
you have to pretend like you're doing okay when you're not.
Can you imagine if everyone was willing to be vulnerable the way that our elder brother
is willing to be vulnerable and share the personal narrative and give us an opportunity to
experience the world through his experience?
Subhan Allah. Why are you not able to do that?
And it's not because you're a bad person, but it all goes back to fundamental blocks
of how do you create trusting, supportive community.
Each of us has something to offer.
And if you become the companion that you strive to have for yourself
and you let people just talk sometimes and express without listening to respond but just listening
to understand so you can get all the stuff out and all the clutter out.
Do you know what I mean?
And then we can benefit by just hearing somebody and holding what it is that they're
holding.
No one can benefit from the good you don't do.
And what's demonstrated here is not just the wisdom of experienced and years lived in this
world, but the willingness to say, I'm going to expose a little bit about me to
be able to elevate what it is that the gathering takes away and allow for my
vulnerability to be something that its bravery brings benefit to people.
You got to be willing to do some of that also.
Yeah. Go ahead.
As I
used to be
I have a lot of long friends that happen to you know end up in the
mountain. When I said a long time that means from college when I was bachelor very
very long time
we met here and then you know somehow we end up together now come to the
ideas that one of us
have you know
I'm one of them but I'm not
so president in the center
plus
so
and then start getting
so me as a person
I always have objective in life to have a legacy have purpose
so I'm not like wealthy enough let's say
donation create some sense of impact to the um but that is our part of something
So I end up supporting the ideas of the master with that frame in back my
head in my mind but I have to see the fact that when I just started
exactly that what you just said before somehow brothers from from my community
you have to be ready
but I know
that very long a lot of close friends
some people make fun of me
so I'm not a person
but in a way I
better think that all the
but I don't know if I'm doing this right right now
I can I can see that you have lot of
community this complexity I never
understand all of us are Muslim all of us
all of us know all the
I don't think
everyone I know all the people they know
but
somehow couldn't help it not
to
you know so so far I'm doing first I'm trying to clarify
but it didn't change anything and then I'm
just quiet
I don't know this is
everything isn't always just qualitatively right or wrong and when you live in a world that
is about streamlining and efficiency and quantifiable metrics and KPIs and all these things I mean
it doesn't work that way Right?
Like you know we have Can everybody see this?
This is a cup.
Right. Okay. And here is a bottle.
The bottle is smaller than the cup.
Mhm. Right.
This water fills to the top.
Let's assume this is also filled to the top with water.
Both of these have water.
Both of them cost the same.
This has more water.
This has less. this would be the better option, right?
Because more is better than less.
All other things being equal.
Does that make sense so far?
That's how we see things a lot.
But our tradition, ethics are situational.
They're not always just black and white.
So, say for example, there was a person, you all, who might have jobs.
You have your first job opportunity.
Someone offered you a stable job as an accountant and said, "I'm gonna pay you $100,000
a year to be an accountant, but you also had the opportunity to pursue your passion
to become an activist or an artist, and you didn't know how to decide between the
two things."
And then the accounting job came back and said, "I'm going to give you $30,000 more
to be an accountant."
If these two things were equal in the beginning and you didn't know how to decide
because they're equivalency, then the added benefit of 30K makes this the better option because more
is better than less.
But I still don't know how to decide between the two because it's not a quantifiable
metric of assessment. It's qualitative.
Ethics are not measured in a quantifiable mode.
They're measured in a qualitative mode.
If I asked you what is Islam
or somebody took their shahada here right now and you had to teach them Islam, most
of you objectively, I'm comfortable in making assumption would just give them a bunch of things
to do and not do.
Right? You don't want to turn this religion just into a set of rules.
One dimension is practice.
A very important practice dimension.
But we have a very deep theological tradition, a very robust spiritual tradition, a universal set
of ethics and values.
And those three all inform practice.
When you get confined in this bucket of what is the right or what is the
most correct and everything is black and white, it actually counters a lot of the way
our religion develops. Orthodoxy in Islam was rooted in diversity of opinions and different ways to
get to certain things.
Certain things were absolute.
There's one God. That's it.
It's not a negotiable.
Do you know what I mean?
But there was a comfort that different people would do things in a different way.
Imam Ahmed's students asked him about praying behind someone who does not redo woodoo after their
nose bleeds.
in the humble school that this breakthrough will do and they weren't
kind of you know self-elevating in an unhealthy way.
They just want to know what do we do if the guy behind us doesn't follow
this hookum.
Im Ahmed says to his students, "This is a good question that you've asked,
but would I not pray behind Imam Malik or say Mus
even where they had a different opinion?"
The orthodoxy embrace this.
It's a modern phenomenon that I have to just know the right answer or the correct
way or we personify Islam into an individual saying, "What does Islam say about this?"
Islam is not a person you can go and ask.
It would make it a lot easier, but that's not how it functions.
And if it didn't function in the ways that it did, it would be harder to
have an accountability mechanism back to us that says we have to make choices and decisions
for ourselves. And sometimes it's not going to be good or bad or right or wrong.
Sometimes it's going to be a choice.
And what it'll fundamentally yield is more of a choice.
Allah tells us
that we guided you to two nudged.
The nudged is a tough path to traverse.
Both of them are
two things. You say
every day so many times in a day and then Allah says
guide me to a straight path.
I brought you to two paths.
You're at a crossroads.
How do you make a decision?
Akaba, you're not going to make it to the Akaba.
The Akaba in classical Arabic refer to the summit of a mountain or the valley between
two hills that when someone was seeking sanctuary from some kind of harm, they go to
the akaba
and the verses that come after
you want to think of like the analogy of going up a mountain.
You're not getting to the top of the mountain.
What does it tell you?
Right? that you emancipate, set free the one who is enslaved
or on a day of difficulty, you still feed someone who's hungry.
This is being revealed to a mechan population that's being persecuted.
And who are the people they're going to feed?
Most of them are not Muslim because there's not so many Muslims to begin with.
And even when a lot of them don't have anything, they're being told feed somebody.
Wow.
Right. An orphan who has proximity, closeness to you, relation or somebody who's Mskine.
This literally just in the dirt.
You're missing all the signs that are going to get you to the top.
And so much of it has to do with choices that you're making, decisions that are
going to be rooted in situational ethics.
And you can have lip service and say I believe this or that.
But how does your decisions actually own up to the things you claim are your beliefs?
For us, outcomes are not the only thing that we yield.
That's what whiteness brings us to.
It's always about the grade you got on the test.
It's always about the job that you got, the credential, the degree, the title.
The outcome is the goal regardless of how you made it to the outcome.
I just got to get to that place.
Doesn't matter who I step on.
Ours is a tradition that teaches us that yes, outcomes are important, but arguably just as
important, if not more so, is the means that's bringing you to the outcome.
And the udger is in the struggle.
My job is to be Muslim.
May Allah make it easy.
Right? I came here to Juma today.
Juma didn't start till I got here.
Do you know what I mean?
You and I are in a place where literally where we work, there is a place
to pray, right? Alhamdulillah.
How could we be measured by the same metric that people right now are still praying
in the rubble of masid and Gaza?
The achievement is not rooted in the fulfillment of the act.
The auda
and recognizing hadith that tell us that the person who recites with fluency, they get a
reward. The one who struggles with it, they get twice the reward because the is in
the struggle. And it's hard to be the only one that exerts ethics.
But if you're doing it, you don't know what's going to be placed in someone's heart.
The prophet still demonstrated rahma at the aftermath of th and then everybody became Muslim.
But it was a process that got to a place that you just take care of
what you need to take care of.
Allah is going to take care of what he needs to take care of.
It takes a little bit of light to push away darkness.
The audger is in the struggle, not in the ease.
And when you are stepping up, you get the benefit.
And this would be the last thing I say.
I know we got to pray Mr.
I said I would come back to this.
Our community started in 1978
with five Muslim students.
In 2008,
I brought them back to anar in a basement of a church.
It was a soup kitchen we were renting out while our current building was being constructed.
And there was a few hundred people breaking fast with us in 2008.
This is 30 years later.
And I introduced two of the five people who founded our Islamic center.
Leil Ashkari Bari Khan
and all kinds of people were going and thanking them.
A young girl by the name of Sumra came into the room and she said because
she was late, what's going on?
and why is everybody around these people?
And I said, these are two of the people who started our center, Bari Khan and
Leila Akri. And I introduced them to everybody
and they're just expressing gratitude.
And then Sumra went to Bari and she said, "I don't know who you are, but
you should know every night thousands of people make dua for you."
And Bari couldn't stop crying.
When our building opened in 2012, I brought them back to see the space,
the fourth floor of a fivestory building where we have a malah wood facilities office.
They got out of the elevator.
There was people sitting in a lounge and I introduced them.
They were very appreciative the same way as the people before were.
We went into my office, had a conversation.
When I was coming out of the office, the people who I introduced them to had
bought flowers and chocolates for Bari and Ila as tokens of their gratitude.
Bari said, "I appreciate you giving us these gifts, but I want you to think about
is what you're going to do while you're here so that when you come to visit
30 years from now, somebody's going to buy you some chocolates."
Wow.
We prayed our last Eid prayer with seven or 8,000 people in a park in the
middle of the West Village and most people went home.
New York's a transient city.
Our community to access our building has to fill out a visitor form.
70,000 people have filled out this form in the last couple of years.
This Ramadan that just passed, we had nine charity, 10 charity campaigns that raised about $8
million
from 52,000
donors for various causes globally and locally.
We fed a thousand people a night fortar
gam in the thousands.
These people started it all in 1978.
Nobody can take that away from them.
Every prostration,
every shahada,
every opportunity of healing and growth
came from them. Not just being people who had an idea, but acted on the idea.
They didn't know what it was going to turn into.
And we just bought a $17 million facility a few blocks away.
17 million. It's in Manhattan.
17 17. Yeah. 70.
Oh my god. Yeah.
Don't give me I'm like m I'm coming to your center.
Renovation, construction, all in.
It's going to be about $22 million.
Mashallah. And we know it's going to benefit
a lot of people in generations to come and be a source of increase.
Something happens in New York, people feel.
Why do you all know who Zahani is?
Do you know? How is that something that you have heard about?
things happen in New York is different than it happens someplace else.
He's not the first Muslim to run for mayor.
But these people, man, they were the ones who they started the whole thing.
I want you to think about this.
The same way they benefit from the
what if you started something that then became a cause of hurt for people generationally?
You built something and you weren't willing to acknowledge the gaps
and then every time somebody was left out because of the way you built it,
that's still coming back on your record.
Do you see?
We want to build like these people without any doubt.
Literally thousands of people make to offer them.
And if you're the only one that's doing something, you might be the most important person
who is interjecting baraka that at least when the records are shown, there was still somebody
who is committed to something bigger than themselves.
And that could bring the baraka that allows for something to outlast
our time in this world that could be transformational in terms of the generation that comes.
And that's where you got to believe in it, right?
It's not just slogans.
When the hadith tells us you go to Allah one hand's length he comes to an
arm's length. You go an arms length he comes to a fathom.
You go walking he comes to you running.
This is divine promise.
You take a step to Allah he's going to come to you running.
Do you believe that in the way that you live?
Do you believe that your wealth is actually Allah's wealth?
It's not yours. And how you spend it is not because it's for you.
It was given to you and you are part of the asbab of how it is
utilized and brought in a mode of benefit.
But our theology is meant to not be spoken.
It's meant to be lived.
And if we had more Muslims who are people of consciousness that just believed
that if I take that step, Allah's promise is not like a human's promise.
He's going to come running.
you would see spaces filled with confidence rooted in these ways.
Don't let somebody else do what you can do.
Bring all of your light and luminosity.
And I want you to think what this space would look like, not just a year
from now or five years from now, 10 years from now, 20 years from now.
Challenge your leadership, but support them.
Define what success means to you.
And once you have that in mind, think about the steps that you work backwards to
getting to that place and allow for yourself with strategy to bring your own skills as
well as a vulnerability of your experience to shape a house of God that draws attention
not to the house but to God for anybody who walks in through the doors.
And you don't have to water down tradition, pretend that we are something that we are
not.
still rooted in what our dean bases our dean upon
and you build it in a way that is just about the pleasure of our God
rendering benefit for his creation and even if nobody else comes and it's just this group
man that's still good you're just trying your best that's where the udger is in in
the attempt to get it done not in the fact that it only was worth it
if the achieve achievement was this one way.
Does that make sense?
Yeah. I don't want to cut you off.
No. No. Please. Please.
All
we begin this supplication in your name, ya Allah, and beseech you to send your choicest
salutations upon your most beloved sau.
We ask that you shower your infinite mercy upon this gathering.
Granting each and everyone who is present herein in our loved ones only the best in
this world and the best in the next.
We ask ya Allah that if all of us are meant to be together only at
this time, at this place, whether we are young or old, male or female, regardless of
our race, our ethnicity, our social class, our country of origin, our cultural heritage, if our
individual hearts are meant to be in the presence of all of their hearts that are
gathered here only at this time, at this place, then gather us all together again in
the best of places in the world beyond this one.
Increase us, ya Allah, in all that is good.
Make us amongst those whose presence serve as a reminder of your existence, a reminder of
your mercy, a reminder of your love.
Help us to be those who utilize the spiritual gifts that you have endowed us with
to bring true benefit to those who are around us as well as ourselves, both in
this world as well as the world beyond this one.
those who remember that for every step that we take in this world, we are informing
the place that we will be in the hereafter.
Ya Allah, make us people of your Jenna.
Allow for us to take advantage of every opening that you offer to us for our
benefit.
Make us the reason that people have hope in this world.
And through us, bring relief to all those who are in a place of need.
Through us, ya Allah, feed your creation.
Through us, Ya Allah, clothe your creation.
Through us, Ya Allah, give shelter to your creation.
Through us, Ya Allah, be generous to your creation.
Through us, Ya Allah, give hope to your creation.
Through us, ya Allah, be merciful to your creation through us.
Ya Allah, love your creation.
and help us to develop a healthy love of ourselves that enables us to go out
and try our best every day that we are in this world.
Make us those, ya Allah, who do not live with fear any longer,
who don't seek to just simply survive in and for this world.
But help us to be those who empower and strengthen one another to truly honor the
mam of being a sister and brother to each other
so that we might build for ourselves what no one else is going to build for
us.
The world is filled with so much difficulty, so much distress.
There are people who we share community with who are holding pain that they don't know
what to do. Help us, ya Allah, to be a source of healing and never to
be a source of harm or hurt.
And for any one of us who is holding our own difficulty,
let not any one of us feel alone any longer,
but bring to us those who will be the best of our helpers and supporters.
Arrange our hearts with those hearts that are gentle and tender
and make us from amongst those who have the blessings and benefits
of true companionship
that helps us to remember who it is that we are supposed to be and enables
us to get there with kindness and consideration.
Bless this space, Yub, and make the Muslim Wellness Center here in Atlanta a means of
benefit for all of your creation.
Bless the leaders, the volunteers, the contributors,
and help them to grow this place
in pursuit
of all things that serve as reminders of what this dean is built truly upon.
Make it a place of replenishment, a place of revitalization,
a place of growth, a place of healing.
And never let it be a place where anybody feels any type of pain, hurt or
harm.
Forgive us, ya Allah, for anything that we might have done to cause shortcomings or obstacles
in the lives of any of your creation.
and help us to move forward from this place
in pursuit of trying nothing other than our very best
so that when we stand in front of you on that day we might be able
to say that we've fulfilled the purpose for which it was that you created us.
We ask ya Allah that by the baraka of this gathering you accept our dua.
That by the presence of the righteous that are here you accept our dua.
that by the sincerity of the most sincere that are here, you accept our dua.
Make this community always a means of benefit and blessing for your creation and allow for
each one of those who come into its doors to be given nothing less than the
best in this world and the best in the next.
Protect us always from hearts that are not humble, tongues that are not wise, and eyes
that have forgotten how to cry.
Forgive us for our shortcomings and guide and bless us all.